and there's more baby news check out
nick cannon smiling big time in the
hospital as he introduced onyx ice cole
cannon his 11th baby but is first with
photographer lenisha cole and while she
documented her pregnancy along the way
she did not reveal nick was the dad
until yesterday the stork is on the way
we'll see how it trickles down
if you're having a hard time keeping
track we got you here's nick's
complicated family tree the 41 year old
has fathered nine children with six
different women there are two more that
we know of on the way including one in
the oven with 31 year old abby de la
rosa it looks out of this world it looks
out of the norm so
naturally yes i could understand
everybody's distaste and disagreeance in
the way that i have chosen to live my
life
abby was candid about her open
relationship with nick on the podcast
lovers and friends in a polyamorous
relationship doesn't mean you have low
self-esteem or low self-worth i become
hyper sensitive when people attack me
and my motherhood in his announcement
post nick acknowledged the backlash
writing please project all criticism and
cynicism towards me and not the loving
and precious mothers of my children
[Music]